thanks very much to play data for
inviting me and and thanks very much for
: even though I know the matches on my
talk is based digital image processing
so it's an area that I got into in my
PhD and postgraduate studies I think
that there's a lot of em interesting
material in the area in the whole field
that's really good for looking at
signals and any kind of signal
processing so fields such as seismology
and econometrics speech recognition and
then bridging out from signals to images
in two dimensions this is applied in
like ultrasound and computer vision some
machines and robots vision and satellite
imagery which is where my PhD studies
came in with analyzing images from
satellite observations so the image I
put up right now is of a handwritten
digits eight and it's flicking between
the actual pixel values on the image
itself and so you can see that we're
looking at things like noise in the
image and and different thank you
different values you know that the eight
isn't just a consistent signal around us
my postgraduate and PhD studies were on
the analysis of satellite imagery this
is an image from the Soho spacecraft and
it's an image of the Sun in the center
represented by this white circle and an
occulting disk that black saves the
brightness of the Sun and it's an
immediate atmosphere and then the
surrounding material is the corona and
Beyond and we're looking at a coronal
mass ejection which is an eruption of
plasma and magnetic field so the
drop-off in intensity in this image is
massive because of the brightness of the
Sun that's dominating and so image
processing techniques are used to do
things like correct for that intensity
drop path distinguish the features that
were interested in such as the
characterize the structure of the CMA
itself to track its evolution but
suppress the background suppress the
Stars sometimes planets move through the
field
you so this is where my foray into image
processing came about and so when
analyzing the images this is kind of a
snapshot of what we would attempt to do
by taking these two-dimensional
observations and analyzing them from two
different points of view here so this
top image is showing a snapshot of the
inner solar system where we have earth
the two stereo spacecrafts now on either
side in their orbit a couple of other
planets and the Sun in the middle so
when they image a coronal mass ejection
we see stereo aids observation on the
left and stereo B's observation on the
right and so we're analyzing this image
from two points of view and that's a
plane of sky projection that we're
trying to characterize the structure and
step it through time to understand the
evolution of that material as it
propagates through space and so one of
the models that we apply is elliptical
ty point and using those and they're
kind of like confined solution space
based on these observations and build a
model to try and get it the true
kinematics and morphology of this
eruption and so this is where the kind
of pipeline comes in of working from
these 2d observations to building up 3d
observations or 3d models that can kind
of and constrain the physics that we
think is happening now I'm working at
Royal Mail and I'm working as a data
scientist in the team there I went
through the pivot go sgds program and
Royal Mail is a vast M company with
amazing amounts of data across the
network of the UK that's been gathered
in the last 500 years of the business
and they've built up data science team
to use our various skills to analyze
that data that they have for a multitude
of projects across the business so for
example some of the projects can involve
the marketing side turn customer
segmentation and looking at systems
recommenders to our business customers
and for example delivery windows were
electrifying fleet and we want to
optimize routes generate sales and of
course forecasting mail of
across the network of the UK so brings
together a lot of different skills and
we have a team of various M scientists
from different backgrounds such as
biology across to em physics and all
these different skill sets come together
to kind of build that Unicorn team I'm
one of the areas that I'm exploring
today with you is digital image
processing as a field where inherently
what we're trying to do is detect
feature X as distinct from environment Y
so any researcher may be interested in
this across any of these disciplines and
the kind of things you're gonna look at
are noise in your signal so if you have
a signal at the top here that you want
to study this is the ideal signal and
there's various levels of noise that are
involved in images you may want to look
at structure from butterfly imagery
right up to I think this is a nebula
structure motion through time steps of
the images so here's to moving objects
vehicles for example and characterizing
the things that you measure in the image
so for example facial recognition so
modeling a face with an ellipse here
modeling the movement of a hand and the
fingers by other M elliptical structures
and one of the big things is to overcome
human error and bias so you want to be
able to make things reproducible by
building an algorithm that can analyze
the images or the signal that's about
reproducible and overcomes one observer
maybe looks at something in one way and
another looks at it in a different way
many of these kind of techniques may
have been seen in some like social media
nowadays for example and snapchat
there's different filters that can be
used detect your face and put a mask on
it Facebook they have the M tag my
friend Instagram all of the different
filtering that happens and Photoshop
where you kind of get to play with a lot
of these techniques yourself so the
field of image processing pulls together
a lot of different domains
your math stats and physics comes
together with your optics and the signal
processing domain but on the other side
you're looking at machine learning and
like recognizing patterns and building
that artificial intelligence system to
ultimately feed a computer to understand
how to interpret the images and make
decisions about what's happening in an
image and so and put this together to
just show some of the steps and I'll go
through some of these where you have the
acquisition the image you manipulated
some how you segment different parts you
want to represent things in the image so
they ultimately get that understanding
and that's your output depending on the
object or fields that you're in and
studying so digital image is a sample 2d
space in regular grid so this is a grid
that's like the first image that I
showed with the figure 8 in it and so
your quantizing that grids and this is
your pixel space that you're building up
and so that's how you're representing
the images this matrix of integer values
but that human bias that I showed you is
something that's important to
acknowledge so if we have a stepwise
function and you're representing that as
an image that's the actual illumination
step wise but the perceived brightness
of the image you can kind of see the
gradient that seems to be across each of
the lips in that in the top image it's
not actually there so we're overcoming
that bias that the humans have and if I
show you this the background has a
gradient along but the inner rectangle
is actually the same shade does anybody
not believe me
so you can kinda see and of course we
see this all the time in optical
illusions so you as a human want to say
there's a white square in the top left
or that shape a is actually smaller than
shake B or there's no way that those
lines between the stacked cubes are
parallel and and I want to ask what
color that dress is to me it's blue and
black does anybody not see it as blue
and black yeah so you may have seen this
as a phenomenon that went viral and over
a year ago I think so image processing
is kind of understanding this and
getting a computer algorithm to
understand how to transform the domain
and the range of the image so if we have
the image of the Terminator here you can
represent that by the value of those
pixels and move that around and interact
with it in that kind of a format and so
the key stage is in that digital image
processing and kind of pipeline you can
work from your problem domain whatever
that may be any researcher in any
discipline if somehow acquired this
image so for me in astrophysics it was a
source system being the Sun illuminating
a coronal mass ejection we have a
optical system on a satellite and that's
realized by this digitized output image
enhancement we've heard before about and
contrasting images so that the human eye
can best see things and it's the same
with the computer you kind of manipulate
those values of the pixels so that you
can best characterize and structuring
them morphological processing is kind of
the growing and thinning of the pixels
so here there's an example of a
fingerprint and different mathematical
operations on how you grow out and this
is a binary image grow at those white
pixels or shrink them it can reduce the
noise or you can also join up and parts
of the and fingerprints that are
actually one part of the continuous loop
segmentation is separation of and parts
of the image such as the feature the
object that you want to look at so the
distribution of the
pixel values you can see a clear
separation in this very kind of clearly
separated image so that you can take
this and I think I think there's some
sort of a crowbar take the MA without
the background and the shadow is gone
now and then how you represent that and
describe based on this quantized space
that you're working in you build up a
picture of what's actually being
realized in that digital output so these
are two ways subscribe the feature that
M being observed in that pixel space and
when you have all these measurements
you've described but in the image you
can move into recognizing objects this
is a snapshot from the iris dataset
where the length and the width
measurements that you would have gotten
out can be used to cluster and identify
the different objects so the different
plants in that data set and this feeds
into computer machine learning so an
example here of detecting all of the
pedestrians that are moving and
realizing whether they move in or out of
a storefront and Counting the volume of
people essentially that have been inside
or outside of a shop at any point and we
see examples all the time in deep
learning and especially nowadays with
classifiers of images so if you want to
input an image of a dog that's a load of
pixels that's thrown into that deep
neural network and you're looking at
these combinations of the edges that are
identified so there's a filtering
process happening here to collect those
edges and how they interact and they all
build up this feature space that you're
working with on top of your labels to
find that best fit to classify oh yeah
there's a dog in this image and so this
is really important for robotics and AI
and getting the rights and overcoming
that bias I'm see articles nowadays as
well that we're inherently putting our
own bias in how we train and models and
features so we've seen that real simply
with the optical illusions so autonomous
cars is a really important place to get
this right and so I have a quick
notebook
um of some examples that I put together
of these
if anybody wants to work along with me
you can download it from this link and
you can download it later it's in a drop
bomb drop box and and then if you like
what you see please feel free to contact
me on LinkedIn or Twitter and I have a
blog data science unicorn comm that also
tweet tapes and articles of interest and
resources for data scientists so just
move to the jupiter notebook
this notebook essentially builds off the
sk image M module which is really nice a
lot of the work that I showed you that I
did in my astrophysics studies I worked
in a code called IDL and we had to kind
of build up a lot of what we wanted and
ourselves nowadays there's loads a nice
inbuilt functionality in Python so some
of the examples I can step through here
and I'm not gonna live codes I prepared
this before so loading in the SK image
module and then you can load in an image
of interest to you so I'm gonna load in
an image of a stump because I worked at
Royal Mail and so this is a grayscale
image because so much easier to work
with and color image of to split at the
different color levels yeah question
sure sorry thank you for pointing at it
yeah
and so when we plot an image you may
obviously be first interested in looking
at the histogram that image and so you
can kind of see straight away that
there's three layers to this image the
histogram and both the image kind of
convey this so the bust itself the
background is dark and the letters of
the first and class postage this is a
noisy image if your image doesn't have
noise you can add noise because there's
always noise in the real world I guess
we may want to enhance the image somehow
so and I look here at changing the
distribution so here's the low contrast
image and we have the histogram and the
cumulative histogram in red contrast
stretching we stretch that out because
we have all this unused space here and
you get a better contrast of the
background against the image that you're
looking at which in this case is the bus
through the first and then histogram
equalization is a technique you can
apply an adaptive equalization another
one similarly so ways to manipulate that
histogram value to isolate parts of the
image that may be most interested in
this is your contrast enhancement
clipping the image based on that and
what we saw a bit there like all of the
histogram pixel values were sitting in
an upper range click back so you're
actually getting a better contrast
without having to worry about stretching
it's just a hard threshold I've put this
color filter on now
and interpolation so this is a way of
smoothing the image so a lot of the
noise and an image is grainy and a kind
of basically hot pixels around the image
you can apply an interpolation so
smoothing the image based on its nearest
neighbors
so by cubic interpolation is applied
here and you kind of you can see that it
smooths some of the detail as well which
is a side effect but you've smoothed out
a lot of the noise
and later for things like edge detection
that's really important because your hot
pixels will go mad when you're trying
and isolate edges in the image so you
need ways to suppress them and this is
one fundamental way there's cool ways in
like and different types of wavelet
transforms and things you can apply I
don't know why I inverted the image just
different ways to represent things
different people may look at it in
different ways and segmentation what I
talked about briefly before so here I've
just arbitrarily drawn lines to say okay
I think this is the backgrounds dividing
and this is the text so you can clip
each of those and relative to the pixel
values in the image that you're
interested in and intensity contouring
so all of these hot pixels are kind of
getting them contoured based on the
whatever I've said it as here
I think AHA so this image is normalized
between 0 and 1 and so we've outlined
the letters outlines a contour around
the whole body and outlined the border
of the background so you kind of see how
we're getting towards detecting the M
objects in the image and so clipping
that again you can set those thresholds
again not just hard threshold in here
segment the image and now we've got a
flat representation and one zero of your
features of interest versus the
background for example and then if I'm
going over time please edit me the edges
you can apply basically a derivative is
a lot of edge detection is fundamentally
ER and based on so applying a derivative
you get the rate of change in the image
so steps in your intensity of pixel
values so you can outline the imagery in
in a way like this to get the picture
and then there's nicer ways where you
apply a smoothing as well and
and draw the pixels around the edges by
a chaining method to overcome both the
noise and highlight what you're
interested in in the image so we're
getting at the edges at this point
overcoming that noise using wavelets
here to die noises and again you can see
the side effects and there's cool ways
nowadays this is just me demonstrating
simple packages makes it so easy for us
to understand some of the ways we can
manipulate the signal for our own
interests and morphological processing
so here we're looking at ways to
represent the images by painting and
dilation of those pixels so you kind of
build up this skeleton here you've
thinned it out or just partially tinned
you get this real nice detail around and
pixels of interest and I think this is a
another way where it applies to methods
this medial axis method of thinning the
pixels into a main kind of spine within
the space when you when you close it in
and then it's put the image contours
over it as well you can see where like
things like image compression kind of
come in here because you're dropping a
lot of signal you may not need yeah I
think the color here is from the
distance that you've tuned in to the
center so you can see like it's kind of
like just pained a little bit here
between these pixels it's a purple but
it's tend a lot to come into this spine
and if I remember correctly what we can
and yeah this is the dilation as well so
real box aversion and yes I hope that
this has been enlightening some of the
like processes that are really easy to
play with and nicely built into Python
module but it helps us understand a lot
of the functionality and capability
behind processing signals for features
of interest in whatever you feel study
may be thanks
[Applause]
okay so question is I think this is fine
for black and white but I'm having tried
to do deep learning on color images with
a lot of in context features do you have
any sort of suggestions for our out of
this the best set of transformations for
color this is all what would you do with
color imagery yeah it's a really good
question it's very valid nowadays and
you can a lot of it depends on how the
image is generated but a lot of images
are generated based on their GP scale or
ym c k and so inherently it's three
images combined together and so you can
process them as a cube of images and
work in em like in Fourier analysis your
work on K space you can kind of look at
images in that way and consider these as
other dimensions so when I talked about
the dimension of time and time steps
that was one example but you can build
out your cubes of images based on that
level of knowledge that's a possible
suggestion but it's a really valid
question because there's a lot of
exploration on what to do with those
levels of details and my PhD studies
were all and white light imagery so here
I was like great this simplifies it in
the first instance
do you pick
sure
yeah
and we just
and
yeah um part part of what I work on is
confidential but um you can see how like
I showed one example of churn modeling
and we're looking at the signal of the
male traffic and volume for example
across some of our business customers
and processing that signal is in a realm
of signal processing where it's really
noisy we're looking for patterns looking
for trends and I thought maybe Fourier
analysis to be nice because in the first
instance if we can like smooth that out
and off you're looking at different
rates of behavior for different
customers and that kind of leads into
segmentation or different ways to label
them the optical character recognition
system is something that I've been
interested in so a lot of the
handwritten letters still have to go
through a manual rotation but most of
the print letters get read by the OCR so
that can locate the postcode and readers
and understand that it can digitize it
and then digitize like the parts of the
address in relation to the postcode Bush
and I'm curious other ways to enhance
that based on like training what we've
labeled essentially by you know
gathering all of this handwritten post
and I've heard like Christmas and
Valentine's it's especially hard to read
red envelopes and if somebody uses a
black ink for example and they are Gator
and egg for a Manuel Manuel Ruiz and
that's the color question again so it's
interesting
and I had a joke with one of my friends
that and my PhD is actually really easy
because my error bars are plus or minus
this one your question is perfectly
valid from the point of view that we
want to ensure we're capturing our
images at least in the same cadence with
regards to processing on board and the
downlink
of the telemetry and yeah there was
there was ways to overcome that in
stereo as a mission was built to make
sure that they were capturing at the
same time and considering the lag at any
point and and then because they were
imaging such large scale phenomenon yeah
yeah we just kind of a Canford in the
errors but the time offset wasn't the
biggest issue it was that one pixel was
such a large distance in the heliosphere
one last question at the back yeah
it's the quick observation is the answer
to the red envelope question ditch the
visible spectrum and go UV or was it
that tend to work yeah definitely I mean
and one of the medical applications was
MRI for example so you can use any yeah
yeah so that's why I'd love to get under
the hood of the OCR and say okay what
are we doing here you know is it the
same as what we used in the CCD imagery
for satellites white light imagery or is
there something else that's going on and
how expensive is infrared versus just
trying to build off the current system
you know all these questions come into
play yeah scientists I just want to see
what happens
you